it's a deal that's supposed to help
lebanon with its acute energy crisis but
officials acknowledge this was about
much more jordan will be supplying
electricity that will transit through
syria in another step toward ending that
it is really country's
cooperation between the arab states that
we are talking about here that we in our
modest assessment has suffered over the
last years and it is time
really to rebuild
the work this is the first time a member
of syrian president bashar al-assad's
government has come to beirut in an
official capacity in more than a decade
syria has been shunned by much of the
world for its harsh crackdown on
peaceful protesters lebanon never cut
ties with syria but relations with
president assad are a divisive issue
here so successive governments avoided
engaging with the syrians until now but
syria's permission was not enough for
the deal to be agreed lebanon's
president and prime minister have said
the u.s has assured it it will not
impose any sanctions as a result of the
deal but in washington the state
department told al jazeera that it has
not waived any of its sanctions that
prohibit transactions with the assad
government recently the abide
registration shifted policy i think
there are two main reasons first is to
to balance or to mitigate
lebanon dependence on
on iran for energy especially after
hezbollah
imported
gas and fuel from iran last year and
second is to maintain u.s influence in
lebanon washington appears to have
turned a blind eye as assad syria
gradually returns to the arab fold but
it insists it won't support
normalization with assad's government
without a political solution to the
conflict in the country but those
exemptions
are not sufficient enough i think in
order to say
that syria is
qualified or is accepted by the
international community especially the
united states to go back
to the arab league but those objections
haven't stood in the way of a deal that
won't provide more than two additional
hours of electricity a day
we the syrian government support all
phases of arab normalization and
cooperation
power outages are lasting 22 hours a day
in a country that's nearly bankrupt and
can't buy fuel and where politicians
refuse to reform a crumbling sector
riddled with corruption
instead they are accused of focusing on
short-term fixes that appear to
prioritize the politics behind the deal
senator al-jazeera beirut